this process will place the state's
actions under the microscope
and we should be mindful of the scale of
that undertaking and the resources
required
to do it properly the exercise of
identifying and disclosing
all relevant information the months of
preparation
and retrospective analysis and the time
that people will have to spend
testifying in public in some cases for
days
will place a significant burden on our
nhs
on the whole of government on our
scientific advisors
and on many others we must not
inadvertently divert or distract
the very people on whom we all depend
in the heat of our struggle against this
disease
and the end of the lockdown
is not the end of the pandemic
the world health organization has said
that the pandemic has now reached its
global
peak and will last throughout this year
our own scientific advisors judge that
although more positive data is coming in
and the outlook
is improving there could still be
another resurgence
in hospitalizations and deaths
we also face the persistent threat
of new variants and should these prove
highly transmissible
and elude the protection of our vaccines
they would have the potential to cause
even greater suffering that we
than we endured in january and
there is in any case a high likelihood a
high likelihood
of a surge this winter when the weather
assists the trans
uh mission of all respiratory diseases
and when the pressure on our nhs is most
acute
so i expect that the right moment for
the inquiry to begin
is at the end of this period in the
spring
of next year spring 2022 and mr speaker
i know
that there will be some in this chamber
and many bereaved families will be
anxious for this inquiry
to begin sooner so let me reassure the
house
that we are fully committed to learning
the lessons at every stage of this
crisis
and we've already subjected our response
to independent scrutiny
including 17 reports by the independent
national audit
audit office and 50 parliamentary
inquiries
already and we will continue to do so we
will continue to learn lessons as you
have done
throughout the pandemic but no
public inquiry could take place fast
enough
to assist in the very difficult
judgments which will remain necessary
throughout the rest of the year and the
remainder of the pandemic
and we must not weigh down the efforts
of those
engaged in protecting us every day and
thereby
risk endangering further lives
instead this inquiry must be able to
look at the events
of the last year in the cold light of
day and identify the key issues
that will make a difference for the
future free
to scrutinize every document to hear
from all the
the key players and analyze and learn
from the breadth of our response and
that's the right way i think to get the
answers that the people
of this country deserve and to ensure
that our united kingdom
is better prepared for any future
pandemic
mr speaker entirely separately from the
inquiry there is a solemn duty on our
whole
united kingdom to come together and
cherish the memories
of those who have been lost
like many across this chamber i was
deeply moved when i visited the
covid memorial wall opposite parliament
and i wholeheartedly support the plan
for a memorial in saint paul's case
cathedral
which will provide a fitting place of
reflection
in the heart of our capital
i also know that communities across the
whole country
will want to find ways of commemorating
what we have all
been through so the government
will support their efforts by
establishing
a uk commission on covid commemoration
this national endeavor above party
politics
will remember the loved ones we have
lost
honor the heroism of those who have
saved lives
and the courage of frontline workers who
have kept our country going
celebrate the genius of those who
created the vaccines
and commemorate the small acts of
kindness and the daily
sacrifice of millions who stayed at home
buying time for our scientists to come
to our rescue we will set out the
commission membership and terms of
reference in due course
and in telling the whole story of this
era in our history
we will work again across our united
kingdom together
with the devolved administrations to
preserve the spirit
which has sustained us in the gravest
crisis
since the second world war resolving to
go forwards
together mr speaker and to build back
better
and i commend this statement to the
house